hello everyone there are a lot of strong
chess tournaments played throughout the
year in the world but I think you'll
agree with me that nothing says badass
as the Russian chess championship super
finals 2017 even even the great grand
Chester or pales in comparison it's it's
tournament played in st. Petersburg in
the state museum of political history of
Russia played by 12 players 12 strong
Russian grandmasters but you can see
that from the quote above the board I
was tweeted some hour and a half ago by
Peter hi Nielsen he says that the
Russian Chess Championship is played by
12 players and in the end Peter Svidler
always wins and it's obviously the case
I mean this is his eighth title to be
the Russian champion he won 1 million
rubles that's like almost $17,000 he
also won a car Renault something I don't
know the exact type and not only that
but he re-entered the world top 10 chess
players by rating so far alexander
greece chuck was in 10th place and now
sweedler kicked Greece Chuck to 11th
place and he topped him by like 0.6
points and yeah I was also very I mean I
heard of this like some time ago that
ratings also have decimal numbers so
this is one of the game from the
tiebreaks after after 11 rounds
Nikita BTO and Peter Svidler shared
first place with 7 points and only half
a point behind them where Donald dubov
and Vladimir fed of save so they had to
go into tiebreaks to decide who will
take the Russian championship and this
is one of the games Peter Svidler in
this game has the white pieces and he
plays C for the English opening we have
E 5 in the night the C 3 so called the
reverse Sicilian of the English Knight
to c6 Knight f3
now f5 and d4 here we have e 4 by the
cube of and d5 by sweedler and it's a
short position right right from the
opening night
CTE 7 was played and this isn't isn't
the best move
better idea would be something like e
captures on f3 and after D captors on c6
it's a pretty forced variation F
captures from G to C captor Sundy 7
Queen captures and after a bit of
capture son G to queen capture screen
captures and after C 6 it's a pretty
equal equal endgame well if you can call
this an endgame it's move not its move
10 but what has three point islands if
you can see that here and black has to
pond island so you know pretty equal but
it's fine for black but after d5 we
could have decided to go Knight c3 7 we
have Knights to d4 now b6 and f3 Knight
to g6 now capturing an f3 doesn't really
give like anything it only helps white
develop his pieces
so after f3 Knight to g6 now we have he
captures F characters on e4 f4 now
trying to kind of kind of cramp White's
position but fiddler doesn't allow this
he needs to place g3 and here it could
get kind of dangerous if okay there is
this idea of Queen to h4 of G captors on
f4 but if white can somehow avoid this
and create this monster center then this
will be almost winning so F captures on
g3 we have h captures and g3 and now
Knight to f6 Bishop to h3 here black can
capture the bishop it's not a problem
but motivo decides to go for Knight g4
it's it's just as good
preparing to remain over the Knight to
e5
we have knife to e6 now now the bishop
is no longer protecting the knight
energy force so Bishop captures on g4 is
a threat so Bishop captures on e6 D
captures on e6 and we have night for to
e5 and Bishop to f5 now and this is now
a very strong Bishop it's gonna be very
hard to kick it away from there even if
you capture it with a piece then it
captures on f5 will create extremely
strong passed pawns okay he ponies past
but and they will be very strong
so c6
we have fish up to III and the Queen to
c7 probably preparing queenside castle
Queen to b3 and here Knight to e7
displayed and here we have castles now
pressuring the d6 pawn but also
preparing a very nice idea b6 is played
and now after Bishop to f4 and Nikita B
to go resigned at the game in this
position and Peter Svidler became the
eighth time this is his eighth time that
he won the Russian chess championship
what's the idea why did he resign well
the idea is pretty straightforward
Bishop captures Knight rook to d7 and
the game is over so if you allow this
for example if you castle then Bishop
captures pawn captures rook captures in
captures rook to d1 check King to c8 and
rook to d7 and it's it's game over you
can play something like Queen to b8 but
after Queen to d1 there is no defense
against rogue to d8 so this is pretty
straightforward
and there is there is a line which maybe
maybe Vic you've considered maybe he
didn't after this Bishop to f4 he could
have played Knight captures on f5 and
this is a somewhat of a more resilient
defense now Bishop captures said it
doesn't really work in White's favor
because you have Knights to e3 attacking
the rook and also now the bishop is
defending the d6 pawn so after rook to
d3
now you capture the bishop and not now
back is actually fine rook the rook will
recapture it and there everything is
okay for black what is better but it's
playable but the problem is after Knight
captures on f5 you don't capture the
knight now you play ecaptions' on f5 and
now you have beautiful pawns here and
after something like Knight to g4 you
still can't allow Bishop captures on e5
Knight to e4 now and now you're
attacking the d6 pawn three times
queenside castle now the rook is again
defending the pawn and now Queen to a3
and now this is overwhelming the attack
on this pawn and here it seems like like
a bee
since the moments to play a move like a
d5 you know if you kept remikit I'll
capture your queen okay you will win the
exchange but but even this doesn't
doesn't work after Queen to c3 you have
to move the Queen
for example Queen here and then you
capture the pawn on d5 black can't
recapture because the point is pinned
if rocker captures rook captures again
you lose the rook so there's really
nothing to play here after c5 Queen d3
preparing to push and this is over so
yeah after Bishop to f4 in this it's a
pretty
I mean it's move 18 so quite a victory
for for Peter Svidler Nikita B to decide
decided to resign this game he had
something something about seven minutes
on the clock so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I believe it this
is the first game I've shown by Peter
Svidler on my channel but it seems I
will I will be showing a lot more of his
game since I guess he's now in the top
10 he will probably get invited to do a
lot of a lot of very strongly
tournaments I would like to thank lamo
Moro for a contribution to my channel
thanks a lot - really appreciate it and
like I said in my previous video if you
enjoy the idea of me showing subscribers
games for example on the weekend or or
one day of the week do do write
something like yeah that's a good idea
in the comments below so yeah as usual I
can check - on my previous videos here I
think all for watching and I will see
you soon